hey guys Lisa here with the quick games
what news update for you
sony has begun rolling out its global
system updates for the PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation Vita systems I should get
one for the car yesterday Sony detailed
the key new features included in the ps4
2.5 yukimura update including the
long-awaited suspend resume function
harddrive backup options and the ability
to search for Facebook friends on PSN
now with the update cooling live across
Europe US and Asia PS Vita owners have
begun listing the featured improvements
that come with the handheld 3.5 firmware
chief among them is the enhanced
accessibility options such as button
real nothing and large text inverted
colors contrast adjustment and zoom
functionality the button remapping could
be particularly useful for players who
use the PS Vita's function as a spare
ps4 controller and for those who use
remote place it to ps4 games to their
handheld shooters are beaches 2 through
your shoulder button has done the
DualShock 4 controller remapping could
give players options to build a button
scheme around this problem in January
Sony revealed that it was stripping
certain apps from the Vita including the
YouTube app other changes have been
noted on your bigotry - including the
removal of the Maps application along
with various tweaks across the platforms
so there we have it which features are
you looking forward to trying out and
which features you think that Sony still
need to add let me know in the comment
section below and for all the latest
gaming news make sure you keep your eye
on Gabe spot calm
you